Let's pray together for day 22.
Today's prayer is a beautiful hymn called "Love Through
Me, Love of God"
by the great missionary Amy Carmichael.
"Love through me, love of God. There is no love in me.
O fire of love, light thou the love that
burns perpetually.
Flow through me, peace of God.
Calm river, flow until
no wind can blow, no current stir,
a ripple of self-will.
Shine through me, joy of God. Make me like thy
clear air,
that thou dost pour thy colors through as though
it were not there.
O blessed love of God, that all may taste and
see how good thou art, once more I pray,
love through me, even me."
Father, we do ask
for the powerful work of God's purifying love in our
hearts.
We pray that we would be filled with the Holy Spirit.
We pray that you would take full control of areas of our
heart and life that we never realized before we had kept
for self.
We pray, Lord, that you would affect deeply
and keep full continually
all of the parts of our heart, our relationships,
our speech, our music, our attitudes.
Would you keep all of them full continually of the
presence and power and purifying work
of the Holy Spirit?
And Holy Spirit, we invite you to do that work today.
If there's any reason why you could not fill us
today, now, and fully control every part of
our life, reveal it to us so that we might turn our back
upon it, repudiate it, and find the fullness that comes from you.
Thank you for giving us yourself as a gift at the moment of salvation.
Now fill us, we pray. In Jesus' name.
Let's continue praying and seeking the Lord together.